we had a question come in from our
viewer Ernesto Caro and Ernesto writes
my biggest curiosity is the pacing of
the story I'm a screenwriter and I love
Comics but I couldn't even imagine how
to Pace a comic book in regard to
dialogue versus action per page okay now
in order for me to answer this question
I need to talk a little bit about this
company I established 10 years ago
actually in 2011
so back in
2011 it was quite clear to me that there
was a real Nexus between graphic novels
and comics on the one hand and film and
animation on the other by which I mean
to say more and more movies were being
based on comic books and graphic novels
for
example most people are familiar with
the movie Road to
predition what most people don't know is
that started its life as a graphic
novel it was written by uh well-known
mystery novelist Max Allen Collins and
it was taken to Hollywood by a fellow
named Ken F lvin who is also the
publisher and founder of first Comics
that published is Zen okay
and
so I KN I knew that there was a real
connection between movies and comic
books and so I came up with this concept
of a company that is called storyboard
graphic
novels and it essentially says to
screenwriters but also producers
directors and actors give us your
screenplay and we'll turn it into a
graphic novel or a comic book
series and this brings up the answer to
your viewers uh
question what happens is this okay after
we sign a contract and we were on board
with a screenwriter who say has a 100
page screenplay okay what happens
is I read the
screenplay and I start thinking
about an appropriate artist for the
genre of the book is superhero is it a
romcom is it horror is it sci-fi right
at the same time I'm doing that I
personally write the
adaptation the graphic novel adaptation
many of my fellow writers in the
industry have asked me hey Steve uh
could I write some of these adaptations
for you thus far I've I've personally
written every
adaptation which is over 80 of them
since 2011 it's probably closer to 100
now the reason I do that is I always
invoke this quote from uh Liam n in the
movie Taken do you remember when he said
I have a particular set of
skills well I do I have a particular set
of skills I know how to take a movie
script and convert it into a graphic
novel script and some of the things that
relate to that are you know how there's
a a a page of a screenplay is equivalent
to a minute on the screen
well a a page of a screenplay is
equivalent to a page and a third in a
graphic novel In other words it takes
more than a one page of a screenplay to
get it into a graphic novel it's going
to be like a page in a third and this
algorithm if you want to call it has
proved correct for like dozens and
dozens of of books so you know I came up
with that algorithm and it works right
but in terms of the facing and what your
viewer
asked you have to know how to take a
screenplay which is written for the
fluid medium of
film and turn it into a script for the
static
medium of a comic book or graphic novel
because a book is static it's panel
after panel after panel after panel it's
called sequential art okay and this is
something because I've done it so
frequently I know how to to do it and
part and parcel of that is also knowing
things like how to keep a page
cinematic by not only not overburdening
it with too many
panels but just as important is how many
words you can put on a page how many
word balloons maximum can go in a panel
so these are all like formulas if you
will to ensure that the story moves
along at the right
pace is still cinematic looking and
isn't overburdened by text which is word
balloons and captions so
again to explain how to do this would be
tant amount to explaining how to write a
movie script right and
um that's something that we don't have
enough time to discuss
here oh sure but I'm curious as a rule
how many word balloons are considered
sort of the standard acceptable per
panel two or
three but it all
depends how many words are in each
balloon
uh when you get into like a soliloquy or
a monologue you may have to uh divide up
uh what the character is saying into
like four
panels because there's also like a
maximum number of words you can put in a
balloon which is like 12 if you really
must know right these are all formulas
that I've worked out right and uh yeah
so pacing
characters cinematic
nature uh how much dialogue to put in
it's it's an art and a
science that's great information thank
you I'm going to start really like
noticing that I think I'll start when I
look at Comics I'm going to really take
notice of of because maybe to to the to
the amateur pointing to myself I
wouldn't totally notice if it's too
clutter like I'll just notice
something's off but ion know why yeah
how many written pages is a comic book
is there a standard well I mean uh comic
books today typically are 20 pages of
story there's a the 20 Page stories
there's also a new movement to have
thicker Comics like almost double-sized
like 40 page books so today a book is
either maybe around 20 Pages or around
pages um but but when you say written a
script that I will write for a comic
it's pretty much uh like one for one a
20page comic might take about 20 pages
of script how long does it take you to
write a comic book the answer to that is
as long as it takes there's no strict
answer sometimes you know you can get up
in the morning your subconscious has
been working you sit down at the
computer and within an hour or two
you've got the script then again you can
have some writer block or some issues
you can't quite uh resolve that quickly
and it could take a month again there's
really no definitive answer to that do
you find personally though that you're
better uh in the morning or uh maybe a
certain time in the afternoon well I'm
not a morning person okay um and I'm
kind of erratic to be honest with with
you you know because I've been in
business for myself for so long I have
to set my own
schedule and uh as a result if there's a
deadline coming up I'll get it
done uh because I have no
option uh so the answer unfortunately is
there's no easy
answer